Mō tātou, a, mō ka uri a muri ake nei
Now that the award-winning Red Zone Recovery Plan has been
signed off by government, we can begin the
work.
What was formerly known as red zone, is
now an area of regeneration.
The consultation that has taken place has
been widely acclaimed, winning the supreme
awards at both the New Zealand Planning Institute
awards and the Local Government Management Awards
Design work for the roading, recreational
facilities, and greenspaces featured in the
plan are the key priorities.
The waterfront is already looking amazing
and our community will continue to drive the
process in partnership with the Council through
every stage of the development.
This month, we’re looking at the timeline
for completion of the various projects within
the Regeneration areas.
The job is massive, covering five areas - over
100 hectares combined.
Most of the work is expected to be finished
in the next two to ten years.
The first work to begin will be roading and
we’ve been receiving feedback from our community
about the roading designs for Courtenay Drive
and the new roading link between Feldwick
Drive, Bracebridge Street and Cass Street.
We consulted with the community recently on the design for the rebuild of Courtenay Drive
and hopefully we'll have contractors on site in July and the work all finished by the end of the year.
In 2018, design work for the sports fields
will be underway and construction of the Riverview
Terraces will be progressing.
Work will also begin on the new roading link
in Kaiapoi East regeneration area, and we
should see the first sod being turned for
the BMX track and dog park.
Well the planning and design of the new reserves and parks is well underway, and we’re working on some
really exciting features.
We’re looking forward to sharing these ideas with the community over the coming months.
Also planned for this area are a food forest
and walking and cycling tracks.
These are all activities that our community told
us they wanted during the development of the
draft Recovery Plan.
Land is also being set aside for a motorhome
and caravan park and for exciting new retail
and business options for the Kaiapoi Town
Centre.
So this is an exciting time for Kaiapoi, and
we want you to be a part of it.
The Kaiapoi- Tuahiwi Community Board will be holding
fortnightly drop-in sessions here at the library
in the Ruataniwha civic centre and we'd like you to come in and talk to us.
Next month, we’ll be looking at the design
for the Riverview Terraces on the north side
of the Kaiapoi River and talk to local developer,
Jedd Pearce.
We’ll meet landscape architect Kevin Dwyer
and check in on what progress has been made
along the Kaiapoi River waterfront.
For more information about the regeneration,
visit any council service centre or waimakariri.govt.nz/regeneration.